français juif vous êtes chez vous ici
dans votre patrie elle vous doit cette
patrie une part de votre identité sans
doute mais une part de sa propre
identité
vous êtes chez vous en france vous lui
avez tant donné à la france la france le
sait la france le 10 la france le montre
et elle s'est levé il y a un mois pour
dire non au fanatisme et non à
l'antisémitisme
les juifs sont chez eux en france ce
sont les antisémites qui n'ont pas leur
place dans la république
cette longue histoire de france sur
laquelle vous êtes pleinement héritier
est aujourd'hui acteur doit continuer
doit se poursuivre avec vous vous aimez
votre pays vous le servait de multiples
façons et votre pays votre patrie votre
république vaudois protection et
affection la france a besoin de vous
comme à la besoin de tous ses enfants
parce que la france elle veut réussir
avec vous elle veut réussir avec tous
les citoyens de france sans distinction
parce que la france a là encore un long
chemin à accomplir
elle ne réussira qu'avec vous ensemble
vive la république et vive la france